là c'est bon donc on un enfyer spécial
sur Kyan Mbappé alors je le
dis quoi je vais vous expliquer
l'histoire déjà non il faudrait qu'on
reviennne là-dessus parce que France
Télévision comme c'est France Télévision
ils font ce qu'ils veulent parce que ils
ont décidé de mettre le truc à 20h40
j'explique au téléspectateurs comment ça
se passe ça veut dire normalement tu
envoies 3 semaines à l'avance les
programmes qui vont passer puisque il y
a la presse et cetera qui va mettre les
programmes sur té té lesloisirs euh les
de semaines c'est bon que des trucs du
groupe le reste on s'en fout t les stars
et cetera après le reste bien sûr on a
on les embrasse euh et qu'est-ce qui se
passe qu'est-ce qu'ils font eux il hier
c'est kan Mbappé ils enlèvent la série
là le soleil est beau là ou je sais pas
quoi là soleil est beau bon le bail là
que j'ai jamais regardé là comment çapp
il y a du soleil surous les tropiques ou
je sais pas voilà comment ça s'appelle
un si beau soleil voilà pareil le soleil
est
beau qu'estce qu'il F mais c'est voilà
donc
soleil est beau terminé et là tu arrives
à 20h40 qui Mbappé
tu donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont décidé dans l'après-midi d'enlever
un si beau soleil et de mettre k MPP
sauf que les gars il y a des règles en
télé je fais pas ça comme ça moi je
connais je suis le mec qui pris le plus
d'amendee donc les gars vous me demandez
ils prennent pas d'amende c'est pas
comme ça ils doivent prendre normalement
si tu déprogrammes ça s'appelle une
déprogrammation tu dois avoir une raison
valable l'actualité ça veut dire le
président veut parler pas le camber le
ah
ouais c'est vrai le gars pas le camomber
pas une allocution du camomber Président
bonsoir à tous ch
compatriot exactement il y a un gars qui
meurt euh voilà il y a gilberdes qui
cocu un truc comme ça non mais je sais
pas un truc d'actu quoi voilà et eux ils
font ça comme ça nous on fait ça les
gars c'est àande direct eux qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont rien au nom de l'info tu fais
ce que tu veux au nom de l'info au nom
de l'info tu veux donc ils peuvent
déprogrammer comme ils veulent ils on
pas c'est pas de l'ct
on il ave la rglation ils jouent avec la
réglementation parce que c'est pas du
New MPP c'est c'est du news c'est pas un
breaking news et c'est un magazine
d'info je t'exlique c'est maouille et
compagnie on aurait fait ça nous
t'exlique DESS non voilà je te le dis
nous serit tomb dus c'est pas
respectueux pour les
téléspectateurs il pr cours de gars je
vais vous appeler C ils font ça aussi
pour faire gonfler la part de marché
bien sûr ça qu' ont fait ils ont fait 2
milli parce qu'ils ont démarré à 20 nous
aussi on le fait sur des prime on
l'annonce simplement eux ils font ce
qu'ils veulent c'est terminé c'est
France Télévision fait ce qu'on veut on
est les rois du monde je peux dire
crashidti va son ne làdedans ça
va vous faire tout drôle c'était sympa
avec Rima Abdou Jabbar mais là je
dire bon Kyan Mbappé donc il nous avait
fait des promotions depuis de semaines
je sais pas ce qu'il a été fout
là-dedans d'ailleurs j'adore Kyan envoyé
spécial je comprends pas je comprends
pas en fait j'ai pas compris je vous dis
la vérité je pas compris non mais toi tu
as compris parce que tu es toujours un
empêcheur de tourner en haond mais je te
dis que moi j'ai pas compris voilà donc
Mbappé voilà Kyan Mbappé d'envoyer
spécial non mais excusez-moi j'ai pas
compris voilà je vous dis la vérité
j'aime bien le gars mais j'ai pas
compris voilà c'est comme si tu dis non
mais c'est vrai n'importe quoi c'est
comme si tu dis Gilles Verdez je sais
pas
moi un défilé de mode non voilà bon
alors il a sorti cette phrase je mérite
l'argent que je gagne ouais alors ça a
fait énormément parler regardez et vous
nous dites ce que vous en
pensez qu'est-ce que vous dites aux gens
qui disent il y a trop d'argent dans le
foot maintenant aujour'
je les comprends quand on te donne une
somme comme ça à la
télé on vous donne des sommes 10 tir en
B vous vous dites wou qu'est-ce que
c'est que ça on dit 100 millions d'euros
pour vous oui peu importe peu importe le
chiffre le plus important c'est vraiment
de se dire que en fait c'est un monde
qui fonctionne différemment et c'est le
monde qui marche comme ça il y a des
footballeurs ou d'autres des gens qui
disent ouais c'est bon je mérite
l'argent que je gagne merci au revoir
oui je mérite l'argent que je gagne je
l'ai volé à personne j'ai pas compris
l'intérêt là de faire envoyer spécial
pas pas compris pour lui c'est pour
parler de sa fondation ou mais pe parler
ailleurs parler ailleurs c'est une
connerie excuse-moi 2 million9 il aurait
fait beaucoup plus ailleurs on a
l'impression un peu qu'il est en train
de faire une tournée d'adieu en
communication avant éventuellement de
partir et de faire quelques émissions
qu'il ne faisait pas avant voilà c'est
un peu l'impression qui voilà c'est un
peu ça qui ressem tu veux dire que ça
répond à un plan comm très précis oui
oui très PRC mais d'ailleurs moi je l'ai
trouvé j'ai trouvé éise Luc
incroyablement douce et gentil avec
parce que tu sais ce que ça ça se passe
parce que ça c'est un deal quand elle
vient faire chier
voà par un grand patron aait laette là
ou voilà ou un petit écolier euh ou bien
péito de Belin je t'explique c'est pas
pareil parce que là elle a un deal donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe elle a dû dire à
kan Mbappé tu le fais tu fais une exclus
elle a fait les bandesannonces avec lui
et C c'était pas sucé là non mais
attendez franchement les gars et donc
elle arrive elle elle lui a passé la
pomade pendant tout le truc donc
forcément C non mais c'est'é un deal
après kanppé il a dû lui dire écoute-moi
bien si tu m'attaques tu met une
question truc je me barre direct etise
lu c'est c'est encore c'est encore le
journalisme à deux vitesses de France
Télévision on en parlera tout à l'heure
avec complément d'enquête qui est en
train d'abîer la marque voilà euh
drastiquement c'est bizarre parce que
c'est c'est pas envoyé spécial c'est pas
du tout la bien d'envoyer spécial c'est
on l'aurait vu plutôt dans dans C à8 si
faire un long un long entretien mais ou
bien même il aurait dû faire un truc sur
Amazon ou sur Canal c'est eux qui ont
les droits de la Ligue 1 voilà il aurait
fait un truc sur Canal plus un beau truc
mais là
UC et Kyan Mbappé déjà je comprends
s je suis désolé il y a plein de gens
qui disent qu' met plein de au chage
parce j'ai rien contre elle mais elle
est très sympa mais quand elle va dans
les sociétés et qu'elle dénonce des
choses derrière il y a 1500 personnes
qui sont au chômage c'est pasise
derrière qui va les qui va qui va les
embaucher je vous dis donc nous de toute
façon on est en train de faire enqu vous
allez voir l'enquête de complément sur
France Télévision il est terminé on va
on va le diffuser là ça y est on va le
diffuser assez vite vous allez voir
l'enquête de complément vous allez
comprendre parce qu'il y a pas de Tom il
y a pas de mytho làdedans ils pouront
venir se défendre sils veulent mais
l'enquête de complément ça va être une
autre limonade que le complément
d'enquête hein je peux vous dire que là
c'est pas ça il lui il est allé loin lui
c'est un fou lui lui c'est un
fou non mais je t'explique tu vois le
complément d'enquête tu regardes plus
une fois complément télévision enquête
de ah ben c'est fini même moi j'ai même
pas regarder je veux même pas je veux
même plus voir je me sens pas bien même
moi j'étais pas concerné je me suis
senti pas bien je me suis senti plus mal
devant l'enquête de complément que
devant le complément
d'enquêteir donc vous dit oui il venait
il venait expliquer qu'en fait il
reverse 30 % des bénéfices société à sa
fondation c'est effectivement un plan de
com il y aura d'autres émissions non
mais il a droit et au niveau de l'argent
donc effectivement il gagne 100 millions
par an 72 en salaire et le reste en
revenus publicitaire ça doit être le
3è 72 en salaire si en brut mais en brut
ex ça fait 56 net en salaire et le reste
par an et le reste des 100 millions brut
c'est tout ce qui gagne en contrat
publicitaire sponsoring et cetera le
plus le le footballleur le plus payé
2 milli par an j'adore Cristiano voilà
en salaire et en revenu publicitaire
probablement un plus fort puisque les
mec est-ce que vous trouvez ça indécent
est-ce que vous trouvez ça normal normal
normal non je trouve ça normal
franchement il fait il fait vendre des
maillots c'est une marque il fait rêver
c'est le plus grand footballeur du monde
aujourd'hui à mon avis ça peut discuter
un des plus grand un des plus grands
donc voilà c'est pas usurpé Voilin c'est
Le Meur c'est le meilleur aujourd'hui là
toi aujourd'hui oui après si je pense ce
qui est fou c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le plus grand footballeur du monde et je
vous jure que c'est vrai il risque de ne
jamais avoir le Ballon d'Or si ça
continue c'est très possible parce que à
part si la France et j'espère la France
va être champion d'EUR la chance qu'il a
c'est que alland qui est à Manchester
City si s'il y a pas de compétition
internationale c'est lui qui devrait
l'avoir à chaque fois et si quand il y a
des compétitions internationales comme
lui il a un pays qui qui qui exactement
qui fait pas des gros résultats
nationaux c'est la chance de mppourd
il a au faute
par MO je trouve seulement que c'est
quand même indcent vu les sommes
l'argument il fait rêver moi il y a
plein d'autres athlètes qui me font
rêver en athlétisme en ski et g pas le
vie ça soit un pe plus Réti
entre du coup tous les jeunes qu' ve
faire comme sport il pas je faire du
javelot du pingong du sa ils veulent
tous faire du foot parce que c'est là
qu' a l'argent Bell voitures les belles
montres ça son un peu
répartiussi je trouve que c'est démesuré
pour courir après un ballon je trouve ça
que c'est énorme je me dis dans ma tête
comment on en est arrivé à ces sommes là
c'est l'offre et la demande l'
expliqué et moi je fais partie des
premiers connards à m'abonner sur les
chaînes pour regarder du foot le weekend
je fais partie des connards à les payer
au stade ma place aussi je contribue
aussi à ce que Mbappé tout C argent je
pay ma place au stade moiû que oui je
pay ma place au stade sur internet quand
j'ai pas payéah quand j'ai a que Bachir
il m'a invité à au Vélodrome
laiss laiss que j'embrasse il m' habité
au Vélodrome mais sinon je pay ma place
on fait partie de ce du système en foot
on est très bon les derniers
championnats du monde d'athlétisme une
médaille le dernier
jourir les jeux en Ju prochain on risque
d'avoir zé m ser pasant d'argent c'est
ce que je dis oui mais c'est pas la
faute du foot c'est privé c'est pas de
l'argent public Mbappé Mbappé c'est pas
de l'argent public pens toi moi il m'a
donné envie de rejouer au foot
donc il va l'entraînement demain et pour
le
realé et non c'est très bien mais il
gagne son argent tant mieux pour luiie
bien s il y a pas toi qu'est-ce qui qui
est d'accord avec Jean-Michel j'aimerais
des oui lài ah alors comment
ça va très bien le chiffre qui était fou
derrière c'est 200000 € par jour
personne ne mérite 200000 € par jour il
ne gagne aucun il ne sauve aucune vie en
plus l'argent pourit tout puisque
regardez la différence entre l'ambiance
dans des stades de rugby et des stades
de foot donc l'argent corrom ENF ça ne
sert à rien et personne n'a
besoin le grand patron français qui fait
travailler milers persones mérite pas
non plus
d'Ar chef
d'reise non mais c'est pas pare c'est
unf
d'reise je suis
d'accord MPP il fait quelque chose que
les autres peuvent pas
faire
je suis mélchon c'estàd audessus d'une
certaine somme on prend
tout je suis mélchon
[Applaudissements]
g plus il endu je comm ça il a cru qu'il
était
làise combien c'est combien d'impôt par
mois MPP par mois il donnebi d'
capable de faire c'est ça aussi mais
heureusement on fait l'honneur d'être
avec nous merci oui écoutez avec plaisir
non mais c'est vrai quand tu vois la B
spéculative c'est quand même un truc un
peu compliqué peut-être pour certaines
qu'est-ce qu'il a tu continue continue
non je peux continuer non mais j'ai
regardé le documentaire sur bckam là il
y a pas longtemps là sur Netflix il est
vachement bien non mais tu disais c'est
des mecs qui courent après un ballon il
que ça non mais le mec c'est un génie
depuis tout
petitou mais justement je trve qu'il
mérit le carrière il mérite le mec c'est
un mec qui un génie du marketing après
moi il y a un truc qui me dérange un peu
chez les footballeurs qui gagnent très
très bien leur vie c'est que il y a
quand même certains mecs qui sont un peu
bas du
front c'est vraiment le mépris alors ça
je déteste je déteste c'est le mépris
c'est ça ça c'est le mépris des bobo des
intellos oh tu joues au foot petit con
et tout mais quel
mépris je dis N
je
déte
[Applaudissements]
mélanch on est deux maintenant
deéch ah ouais franchement il m'a mis
une claque dans la gueule mais pas du
tout et tous les types qui tu vas
retourner sur
PAF trs bien faire tout drôle il y a pas
de problème rigle ça va oh non mais je
trouve que les types là qui chouent dans
des chats et tout ça par la
fenre je trouve je trouve moment
donné déj qui
dans
Isabelle parce que je sais qu'à cette
place toujours quelquun qui va bientôt
mourir sur on est sur
la pauvre mais c'est V toujours qu'
celacun qui va bientôt décéder
ici j'ai confondu ces deux personnes en
tout cas jeevendrai vous voir bien sûr
fa fa la chaise je pare toujours devant
voiture je ferai une Hal comme
onit j'ai regardé Mbappé 7 millions
d'impôts il don 7 millions
d'IMP qui les donne
iciimais bien les don plus il est
30%%tune
fondation il est très généreux qui don
qui
don il est très généreux et humble parce
qu'il le dit pas tout le temps il donne
à la B pierre il donne mais c'est vrai
j'ai rien
cont Méda non
plus m tu vasir CAN en plus il fait
rayonner la France au parc des fr
rayonner la France oui mais ai pour
émission
parallèle non mais le tatouer madame mag
Mad madame retourne dans ta
carance ce que tu donnes aux
associations mais c'est triste que vous
soyez chudmission par
par je te dis fais gaffe toi c'est pas
parce que tu as dansé deux fois sur la
la truite de chouber tu vas me casser
les
couilles c'est une vraie question
pourquoi toi tu fais pas l'émission sur
France Télé par que tu
donnes toute l'année tu donnes à des
associations tu dis pas se association à
laquelle je donne le plus c'est
rayabou
ça c'est pendant les vacances en
canettees c'est en canette et en mergise
qui mange pour qu' mange pour qu'il
mange de 3 kg de mergaaise par jour
c'est bon les gars hein c'est bon j'ai
mes limitees euh tiens